- Hi, everyone, welcome
to our daily "Homeroom".
For those of you who
don't know what this is,
this is really a live stream
that we started during COVID
but have kept up and it's still going on.
But it's really a way to have
interesting conversations
or just to kind of
interact with each other
and talk about interesting things.
Today, we're actually going
to have an "Ask Me Anything",
which we've done a couple of times before,
I really enjoy it.
Hopefully you enjoy it as well.
So start thinking of your questions,
put them on the message boards,
whether you're watching
it on YouTube or Facebook,
and we have team members who
can look at those messages
and they'll surface it to me.
But it literally could be about anything.
I like some of the questions
that are a little bit out of the field.
But before we begin, let me
get my standard announcement
or thanks to several corporations
that have stepped up in the run up,
actually, as soon as they found out
that we were already running
at a deficit pre-COVID.
And that with COVID, our
deficit has grown even more.
Special thanks to Bank
of America, Google.org,
AT&T, Fastly, and Novartis.
And even with that help, we're
still running at a deficit.
So if you're in a position to do so,
please think about
donating to Khan Academy,
every donation helps.
And that's what allows us to
keep it free, non commercial
and reach tens of millions
of students around the world
who otherwise would not have access
to really world class
learning in a personalized way
with interactive software, et cetera.
But with that, I would love
to take some questions.
And so let me see what questions
are starting to come in.
And actually, before I even
start answering questions,
I will give a little
bit of an announcement.
Some of you know that
I've been doing this.
It's not an official Khan Academy project,
maybe one day it will be.
It's very complimentary to Khan
Academy, Schoolhouse.world.
And the idea that actually,
it's myself and some volunteers
have been putting that together,
and that is a way to match
students who need help,
who need tutoring with volunteer tutors.
And it's interesting I've
talked about it before
where I said hey, if you're
a tutor, you can volunteer,
if you're student,
we actually have more
tutors than students.
And so if you need tutoring,
there's an opportunity especially
at high school level subjects.
There's an opportunity for free tutoring
at Schoolhouse.world.
So I encourage and we're expanding it.
It started in Calculus
but now we're expanding it
to Algebra One, Algebra
Two, Geometry, Pre-Calculus,
Trigonometry, or Calculus.
So pretty much any high
school math subject.
If you want free tutoring,
there's a great opportunity
to get it at Schoolhouse.world
so check that out.
There'll be a little form
you have to apply to get in
because it fill it kind of
a very alpha early stage.
But it's a great way.
And you my hope is that we're
able to create a critical mass
of both volunteer tutors
and students who need help.
And that overtime especially
as we get into the back to school,
above and beyond Khan Academy
where you can get help at
your own time and pace,
you can get practice and
feedback and you can get videos,
but there's also a place
to get free in person,
I guess you could say virtually in person
or over video conference, over Zoom help.
So please, please check that out.
So especially if you're
student incidentally.
So let's see the questions
that are coming in.
From YouTube, Osama al Sadie says,
"How many hours a day should
a successful student study?"
And then actually from
YouTube, Sanjay Suknarin says,
"What helps you study more effectively?"
And so, these are related questions.
I would say anything in life
that you wanna get good at,
if you're able to put in a
minimum of 20, 30 minutes a day,
you would be surprised
how far you can get.
So if you're just trying to let's say,
let's just say take math.
If you're just trying
to get better at math,
you literally do 2030 minutes a day,
you will get better at math,
especially on Khan Academy working
at your own time and pace.
Now there are certain things
that just to get started up
and get into the flow
takes a little bit more than 30 minutes.
Like if you wanted to
learn to be a programmer
or become a great writer, but even then,
it's about regular practice.
It's about just showing
up and starting to write
whether it's writing a
creative writing story,
or whether it's writing some code.
And there you might do a longer stretch,
do two, three hours at a time,
or even if you're really in
the zone, do several hours.
But once again, it's all
about the regularity of it.
If you have an exam the next day,
obviously we've all
been in those situations
where we have to cram a little bit.
And I'm guilty of doing what
I'm telling you not to do.
But I think sleep is very important.
So I wouldn't study into
your normal sleep time.
And the reason is, not
only will you be more rest
of the next day sleep is when
a lot of those neural connections
are forming in your brain,
it's when your subconscious
has a chance to really process
a lot of that information.
And so I find that I
could study a good bit
if I get a good night's sleep.
When I wake up in the morning,
not only am I refreshed,
but my brain actually has
understood the material
in a strange way a lot better.
So from YouTube Park Shah asks,
"What do you use donations for?"
Good question, Park.
So a lot of you associate Khan Academy
with things that maybe I have
done, made videos, et cetera,
but what you might not appreciate
and I think I get undue credit,
is that kind of kind of me
is over 200 full-time people
and you might then say,
why does kind of got me
need 200 full time-people?
Well, first, think about the
number of subjects and grades
that we are covering at Khan Academy.
We have Khan Academy
Kids for early learners,
then we go into elementary school,
middle school and high
school, even early college.
That is many, many,
we have over 30 grade level
years of courses, so to speak.
So there's a lot of content there
that we try to cover as
comprehensively as possible.
It's not just creating the videos,
it is creating exercises for
every skill for every standard.
And when we create exercises,
we don't just create two
or three per standard,
we create 20 or 30,
so that you can get as
much practice as you need.
Most students will not see all
of the items on Khan Academy,
but in case they need more
practice, we have that practice.
Then on top of that, when you have a site
that is serving 20, 30
million people every month,
it actually takes pretty
technical sophistication.
Just the server costs on
Khan Academy, pre-COVID,
cost about five, six
million dollars a year.
With COVID, our traffic has increased
by a factor of two to three.
And so then you can imagine
now our server costs
are on track to be in the 10,
you know, approaching 10 million
or even crossing 10 million a year.
Then on top of that all that software
that you see on Khan Academy that's free,
that's non-commercial,
the teacher dashboards,
the interactive, the game mechanics,
be able to keep track of what you know
and what you don't know
and give you as much practice as you need.
In order to write software that can scale
to that many people,
you need a very good engineering team
and a reasonably sized engineering team.
We have 80 engineers, and
you might say, 80, engineers,
what are they all working on?
Well think about all of
the back-end infrastructure
to keep something up
and running like this.
Think about the constant
improvements we wanna do
on the user interface.
And you know, like any piece of software,
there are bugs that we
have to constantly fix.
Then on top of that, think
about the different grade levels
and modalities on Khan Academy.
We're also the official
practice for the SAT,
and we're also the official
practice for the LSAT
and then has a slightly
different software experience.
So that's for the engineering.
And then obviously,
working with the engineers,
we have designers, product managers.
And then we have a philanthropy team
that obviously theirs is to raise money.
So you might say, they're part that
we do need to pay their salaries.
And then we have like a partnerships team.
Where we need to partner with
folks like the College Board,
or ELSAC, or other groups to
make sure, and school districts
to make sure that Khan Academy
is having the maximum impact.
We have an advocacy and research team,
where we're constantly trying to study
how Khan Academy is impacting people
and how we can get better at that.
We have data analytics team
that's looking at the data,
oftentimes in conjunction
with the advocacy and research team
to understand how we can get better.
And then of course, you just
need a subgroup of leaders
to help manage all of this stuff.
So hopefully that explains it.
But I will say and this is
kind of, in the spirit of me,
asking for money if you're
in a position to do so.
Our budget is the budget
of a large high school,
but obviously Khan Academy
reaches many, many, many more
then that would apply.
A social return on
investment of Khan Academy
is very, very, very large.
And you can do some calculations on that
however you wanna calculate
it, it's very large, hopefully.
So, from Facebook, Patricia Atsinku asks,
"What is your favorite food?"
So that might seem like a simple question,
but my wife will tell you,
for me, it's very complex.
And there's a lot of soul searching
because there are things that
my animal brain wants to eat,
that I know are not good for me.
And then when I eat them,
it creates this whole cycle of guilt.
And so it's not clear whether net-net
there's benefits to it.
So I do have a sweet tooth.
I think I've grown up eating
from South Asian desserts,
that I especially like, I
don't know, familiar with,
in Bengali, we say Rasgulla,
Hindi speakers would say Rasgulla,
kind of a, I don't know,
cottage cheese, milk sphere
that's kind of boiled in syrup.
As you can imagine for someone
who has a family history of diabetes,
that is not a good thing to be eating,
but that is one of my favorite foods.
There's also another South Asian
dessert known as Ras malai,
also one of my favorite,
but not a good thing to eat.
So I've been lately trying to
actually cut out all sugar,
the way I work, I find abstinence
is easier than moderation.
That it's very debatable thing.
I'm curious to see whether
y'all feel whether,
how you feel on that spectrum,
whether it's easier to be moderate
or whether it's easier to be extreme.
But for me, it's easier
to just cut it out.
So I've been trying to be more, I guess,
you could say ketogenic
but in that spirit,
I've been able to find some good,
I've been ordering from Costco
and these aren't like some sponsors,
but I eat one of these
kind of keto chocolate.
They're kind of like
Klondike bars, with a stick,
but they're ketogenic.
They have like no sugar, no carbs in them.
So that is my current favorite food,
that is my daily indulgence so far.
Okay, another thing that I
really enjoy is Rose milk.
So take some milk, spill
a little rosewater in it,
and then if you don't
know what rosewater is,
you can usually buy it at like
the local international store
or oftentimes a Persian
store, Iranian store.
And then I put monk fruit,
which is my kind of natural
sugar substitute, very good.
If you're not worried about sugar,
just put regular sugar in there.
That's another one of my favorite drinks.
But as you can see, I have a sweet tooth.
So DLX Coding247 says on YouTube,
"Do you read the YouTube chat?"
Well, the very fact that I've
just read your comment implies
that I am able to read some of it.
All right.
Hacker Russo from YouTube says,
"How can I get a job in this economy?
How to get a job after college?"
That's a really good
question, Hacker Russo.
I don't know your particular
circumstance or skill set
or what you're hoping to get
a job in or where you live.
But my general advice for getting a job,
when I came out of college,
it was a very hot job market.
It was in the late 90s
and I had a degree in
Computer Science and Math.
And so I found it was almost like a,
it was a bounty of opportunity.
Then when I graduated
from Business School,
that was in 2003,
that job market I think,
was much more similar to the job market
that's starting to emerge now.
That was one of the worst job markets.
I remember when I graduated
from Business School,
the Career Services said
this is the worst job market
they saw for MBA since the early 70s.
And my attitude towards that is
just keep putting yourself out there.
When I graduated from Business School,
my then fiance, now wife,
she was in New York.
So I really wanted to work in New York.
And I applied, and I really
wanted to work in finance.
I wanted to work in a hedge fund.
And I applied probably 100 places,
I probably ended up getting
20 or 30 interviews.
And I got none of the jobs.
(laughing)
It's not a pleasant experience,
but it's just every day I just said,
Okay, I'm gonna submit
this number of resumes,
I'm gonna write this
number of cover letters,
I'm going to just put myself out there.
And just every job
interview, every rejection,
that's a learning experience.
And it took a while
but eventually I found,
there was a guy, I was 26
at the time, he was 33.
He was starting a small
hedge fund in Boston,
which wasn't ideal, because
it was 200 miles away
from where my fiance lived.
But he gave me He gave me
an opportunity finally,
and so that was probably
the 30th interview
that I had.
But, if I didn't get that,
I was looking at other opportunities.
I was looking at this,
I needed somewhere, I
didn't wanna graduate
and just not have some
way to pay off my debt
and pay my bills and live.
So I was looking at
whatever opportunities.
Sometimes you can get very
fixated on a particular industry
or particular job type
as I had with hedge funds
but I realized at the end of the day,
it was very important
for me to make a living
one way or the other.
So even though it's good to keep trying
at whatever that aspiration is,
I definitely was looking at
jobs that may be paid less
but I still felt I could
learn something from it
and build my experience
because obviously any pay
was better than no pay.
So I would always index on a job
where you'll learn new things
where people invest in you,
and if they pay decent, or pay fairly,
then that's great as well
but it's more about especially
early stage in your career,
are you going to be able to grow,
are you going to be able to
learn important skill set.
Other things that I would recommend doing
is just be your authentic self.
If you can show artifacts of
things that you have done,
this is a world where in
2003 when I was applying,
I think it was pre-YouTube
and all of that.
Today you could create screenshots
of work that you've made
and explain it and that has two benefits,
people will see the work
that you've created,
and they can also see you explaining it,
that shows that you have
communication skills
and other things.
And so yeah, the more
artifacts you can create
of your work product, the better.
And I think that'll help you stick out
if there's a lot of resumes
that they're sifting through.
So let's see from Facebook,
Osama Ismail says,
"Sal, what are your
strengths as a teacher?"
It's hard to say that you
ever fully know yourself.
But I would say my strengths are,
I usually have a love for
whatever I'm teaching.
In fact, I don't think I would teach any,
I don't try to teach something
unless I'm personally excited about it.
And I think passion and
curiosity is infectious.
I'm a naturally curious person.
So I don't view teaching as
let me just regurgitate something
and hope the other person gets it.
I view teaching as let me show
or help this other person
discover how exciting this is
and how intriguing it is,
and how this is connected
with the universe
and how it helps to understand
our place in the universe.
I would say the other aspects are,
I try to bring when I explain something,
I try to bring kind of a comfort to it,
a relaxation to it.
So when you watch a Khan Academy video,
or if I'm teaching in person,
I try to use the tone that I'm
using now I don't use like,
the next step of this equation
is when the, you know,
that I think stresses the situation
and when folks are stressed,
it's harder to engage in the material.
And I would say the last thing is
and this goes close to the first thing is,
I do believe that you can
understand things best
when you understand that intuition
and when you can see how they're
connected to other things.
And so I definitely try to
do that as much as possible.
I do it for my own brain to understand
that's how my brain works.
And I think it's helpful
for other brain as well.
So let's see other questions here.
So Pronate Hundy from YouTube says,
"How do I maximize my writing potential?"
I'm not a writing expert,
but I would say it goes to
one of the earlier quote,
you know, keep writing.
I think you can't go wrong with that.
Just keep writing, keep
practicing the craft.
And then put yourself out
there, show it to people,
get feedback from people.
Obviously, ideally, feedback from folks
who can give you constructive feedback.
Folks, like teachers, other people
who's writing you really like.
And when they give you feedback,
it's human nature to get defensive,
I get defensive, at least in
my mind when someone says wait,
you could have done this better.
But I'm like, no wait, wait, wait, no,
but I did that for a reason,
and you don't see how
genius it is or whatever.
But recognize feedback is a gift.
And you don't have to take,
not everyone's feedback is 100%.
There's amazing writers who,
early points in their
life someone told them,
yeah, you're not that
good at this or et cetera.
Don't take that too seriously.
Just keep writing.
When people give you feedback,
really try to listen
to what they're saying,
keep iterating on what you're creating.
And I think if you do that,
you have a good chance of
becoming a great writer.
So let's see.
Passad Tota from YouTube says,
"Mr. Khan, what is a good topic to do
to expand your creativity?"
Good question.
I don't know if I have
like any like clear answer.
I think one thing is that you need time
to truly be creative.
In our world today, it's very
easy to get over-scheduled.
And when you get over-scheduled,
you could be doing productive things.
You could be learning things even.
But creativity really
sometimes comes out of boredom.
It comes out of like,
what do I do with myself
for the next two hours?
And I think that's a
very important muscle.
I think other things that I like,
surround yourself with
other creative folks
who like to brainstorm,
who like to think outside of the box
or don't even see the box.
And if you don't have them around you,
seek people out on the
internet, like that.
And if you watch a lot of TED Talks,
you'll see a lot of creative people
and how they think about things.
And there's a lot of people on YouTube,
even people who are doing
kind of fun, silly things,
they're incredibly creative.
And you can tell maybe I
could do something like that.
But at the same time, build up your skill.
You might wanna go into the visual arts.
To be a great visual artist,
you need to be creative,
and it is nice to have some core skills.
If you wanna be a great mathematician,
you have to be creative.
But it's also useful to have
some core baseline skills.
You wanna be a great writer,
creativity is huge, but it's great also,
to be able to write well communicate well
and have some decent grammar.
So that's the best
advice I could give you.
But there's nothing like
surrounding yourself
with other creative people and
kind of feeding off of that.
So from Facebook, Said Elsa Hosta,
"Thank you for your work,
how do you find with some
of these needs to be taught
or which aren't taught yet,
how do you keep track of what do?"
I think the question is,
how do we decide on Khan
Academy what to prioritize next?
We look at,
our vision is to cover all
the core academic subjects
of pre-K through college.
So that's the universe,
so that's math, science, social
sciences, and language arts.
Within that, and I hope in
10 years we have all of that,
but within that we prioritize
what subjects are we
capable of doing well,
especially capable of doing
well given the modalities
that we do we have at Khan Academy today.
And what our subject that
we know a lot of students
have difficulty in or
could use extra support
or don't have access to
world class materials.
So that's why math was kind of
an obvious first place to start.
And then we were moving into the sciences,
some social sciences, it's
kinda going in that order.
But that's what we thought about it.
And we said what's the
core academic subject,
we view it as something
that most students take
or need to take if they wanna
keep progressing academically.
So K-12, that's your math,
all the way through maybe
calculus or statistics.
And then if you go at the college level,
calculus, statistics,
maybe things like differential equations,
multivariable, calculus, these
are things that most people
that they go into a STEM
career for sure are gonna take.
If you think about the
sciences, chemistry, physics,
biology, about the high
school and college level.
If you go to college, maybe
organic chemistry as well.
If you look at the social sciences,
the world histories, the civics,
I would love at some point to do law.
You can debate whether
econ is a social science
or kind of a traditional science,
but econ psychology is something
that many students take.
So these are,
we don't have psychology on Khan Academy
and everything else I mentioned we do.
But we don't have psychology.
But that is something
that I think would be,
something that we would eventually do.
So that's how we think about it.
So, let's see, Minelli
Hernandez from Facebook says,
"Thank you for Khan Camp 2020,
my three children are enjoying
and learning a lot, great."
For those of you who don't
know what "Camp Khan" is,
it's a way to keep everyone
learning over the summer.
If you do a web search for "Camp Khan",
you'll see the resources there.
And it's a way to keep
kids engaged as they do
get ready for grade level courses,
which I highly recommend for any students
or teacher out there
who needs to get students
ready for grade level.
So Siddhartha from YouTube says,
"How to keep focused
on academics in between
so much going on in the world."
I definitely empathize
with what you're saying.
I think there's so much in the world,
some of it in our locus
of control, so to speak,
we can do something about some
of it and depends who we are,
there's a degree to what we
can do something about it.
But then there's so much else in the world
that especially if you watch the news
can make you anxious, make
you worried about things,
but you really can't do much.
Now it's important to be informed,
you don't wanna just
stick your head in a hole
and pretend like the rest
of the world is not there.
But what I try to do is stay informed.
I try to quarantine, not overuse the word,
reading the news and
things like that to about,
max 30 minutes a day.
But the rest of the day,
many of y'all know I meditate every day.
That's a way for me to clear
my mind to still my mind,
and then to just focus on putting one foot
in front of the other and say
what is in my zone of control
that can make myself or
the world around me better.
And then I say, let me do it.
And what I find is if
I start my day early,
and I start taking action and
I start having small wins,
then that builds momentum.
So those small wins could be,
I had a good meditation
first thing in the morning,
I went for a run.
I try to run a mile every day.
So it's not like long distance running,
but I run a mile as
fast as I can every day.
Make my bed I do first
thing in the morning.
And so when I build these ones,
if I'm able to make a video
or two in the morning,
by nine in the morning, 10 in the morning,
I'm like, okay, I made
my bed, I got ready,
I went for a run, I meditated,
I made two three videos,
then all of a sudden I
say, you know what, Sal,
you are a productive human being.
And yes, there's stuff
going on in the world,
but just keep at it, you're
making your positive dent
either on yourself or on the world.
So that's how I attempt to think about it.
But obviously, we all have times
that you just feel a little
bit either bad or just process.
So there's a couple of questions
from Facebook Mayo Withich says,
"Aways wanted to pick
at your reading list.
What are your favorite writers?"
And then there's another
question Osama from Ismail,
second question from Osama Facebook,
"What are your favorite books, novels?"
I've answered this in
different ways before but what,
if you look back here, there
are some of my favorite books.
You'll see some Isaac
Asimov right over here.
I love the "Foundation
Series" for multiple reasons
that one more Isaac Asimov down here,
you'll see a lot of kind of
epic space science fiction here
and I love that because it
just expands your worldview
or your universal view,
beyond the day to day
that we all live in.
We can all of us get kind
of caught up with like,
oh, gotta pay the
mortgage, gotta go to work,
go to the meetings.
There's just the day to day.
Some of its good, some
of it is kind of tedious.
But then, it's great to get
into these universes where like,
Wow, there's this whole, time and space
and what's our purpose and
I feel like it elevates.
And that previous
question about creativity
I find when you when you
read science fiction,
and sometimes fantasy as well,
it takes your creativity to another level
because you view everything,
you by definition, these types of stories
break outside of the bounds
of traditional thinking.
So in that realm, Isaac
Asimov, Dune Herbert.
Dune is one of my favorite
books, Arthur C. Clarke,
almost anything he's
written I'm a big fan of
in the science fiction realm.
If you go outside of science fiction,
I love actually Jane Austen,
"Pride and Prejudice"
most famously, I like
Kurt Vonnegut, big fan.
There's "Candide" by Voltaire,
if we were to go into a
little bit of the classic,
I love Don Quixote.
I strangely relate to
him in a lot of levels,
to talk about someone who's
living in their own reality.
So those are the ones
that stick out for me.
So this Vishva Natarajan,
from YouTube says,
"Do you ever burn out?"
Depends what you define as burnout.
There's definitely been times in my life
where I felt tired and stressed.
And I said, I just need a break.
And you know what?
And it kind of creeps up at you on you,
you're doing well and then a little,
you're getting a little
tired of the board,
but like, no, this is super important,
I'm gonna power through it.
And then before you know it,
you're really not in a good place.
You're crabby or you're
snapping at people,
you're not assuming
positive intent of others.
Your brain is just kind
of constantly worried
about something.
And I've tried to become much more aware
of when I'm falling into that.
The meditation helps a lot.
I think we oftentimes,
it's a global culture now,
but it's definitely a Western
culture and American culture.
Push yourself to the limit
your work is everything
and when you are lucky enough
to work on a social mission,
sometimes I feel like
the work is everything.
There's millions of people
who need the help, et cetera.
But you also have to remind yourself
no matter what your job
is, if you truly burn out,
that's not gonna help anybody.
So I've been learning to
take it a little bit easier,
have my weekends to really
rest and recuperate.
There was a time in my
life, even in Khan Academy,
where I would kind of just keep working
because I am so passionate
about this mission.
But spending two, three
days with family and friends
and just doing nothing,
getting your head into a different place.
Very, very, very important.
And every I get older,
I realized just how much
more important today is.
So highly recommend meditation,
highly recommend breaks,
and giving yourself every
day a little bit of time
to do something that's
unrelated with your core work.
And every week, spend
a day or two at least,
to kind of take your mind someplace else.
You have to do it.
And I think you'll actually
find you'll get more work done
in your regular work.
So many questions, I know
we're already at time.
Let's see there's Passade Tota,
did I play any sports when I was young?
I wasn't your stereotypical
super athlete type person.
I played in the
neighborhood with other kids
in the apartment that I lived in.
The only sport I ever did,
kind of in an organized way,
I was on the wrestling team in 10th grade.
And I enjoyed it, I wasn't bad.
But my only trophy of
substance in wrestling
was having the highest
GPA on the wrestling team.
So you can take that for what it's worth.
(laughing)
On that note, I will let everybody,
this is what I always really
enjoy these "Ask Me Anything".
Hopefully y'all enjoy it, too.
But I'm late for a
meeting I just realized.
So thank everyone for joining.
Tomorrow we're going to have
our head of engineering.
I know they had that earlier question
about what does everyone
do at Khan Academy?
So we're gonna have our head
of engineering, Math Art,
talk about our engineering work
and what we hope to do
there at Khan Academy.
And then on Wednesday,
we have another really, really
interesting conversation
around really just childhood
and how students are raised
and the effect on their
psyche and things like that.
So look forward to seeing
y'all in future "Homeroom".